[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
على النظام بيوم الانتقام
بمعلومات استخباراتيه المانيا تعتقل
ايرانيا بتهمه التخطيط لجنه هجوم باسلحه
بريطانيا تقول ان روسيا تعد الدفاعاتها في
زابوريا كبير
برعايه الامميه وافريقيه بدء المرحله
النهائيه في العمليه السياسيه السودانيه
اليوم
اهلا بكم
سلطات النظامي
مستمره من شعبان
اليوم في شوارع ايران بيوم الانتقام
مضيفين ان المحتاجين
على مواقفهم ومؤكلين انهم سيتظاهرون في
طهران وجميع المدن الاخرى
على حكم الاعدام على الاحكام الايرانيه
حيث مدد برلماني من اصول الايراني
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه دارت في اشد
العبارات ما قالت انه محاكمه وهميه واعدام
لرجلين في ايران بدعوه قتلهما رجل امن
خلال التظاهرات فيما اعرب الاتحاد
الاوروبيه عن صدمته من تنفيذ ايران احكام
جديده بحق محتجين ودانت خارجيه الفرنسيه
باشد العبارات ما وصفته بالاعدامات
المروعه اما هولندا فاستدعت مجددا السفير
الايرانيه لديها بسبب اعدام سلطات النظام
المحتجين الايرانيين
[موسيقى]
يواجه النظام في ايران انقساما بين صفوف
حول طريقه الرد على احتجاجات غير مسبوقه
متواصله منذ اشهر وتترجع الخلافات بين
القمع وبادره التهدئه على ما يرى محللن
مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه
الامريكيه اوضح ان الرسائل المتظاهره التي
بعثتها النظام الايراني تشير الى جدل
داخلي حول طريقه التعامل مع الاحتجاجات
المستمره في وقت اشاره مراقبه لان
الموافقه على اعاده محاكمه عهد من
المحتاجين حكم عليهم سابقا بالاعدام
والافراج ايضا عن معارضين بارزين جميعها
مؤشرات على ان بعض يسعى الى نهج اكثر
ليونه في محاوله اخرى لتهدئه الوضع
من دبي مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفيه متخصص
في جيان الايراني مسعود الفتح اهلا بك سيد
مسعود معنا في هذه النشره الايرانيون على
موعد اليوم مع
مظاهرات او مع يوم الانتقام كيف تتوقع حجم
المشاركه في هذه الاحتجاجات وتداعياتها
ايضا على المشهد برمته
الدعوات كانت واسعه ليله امس
ويبدو بان جميع المجموعات المعارضه
المختلفه فئاتها بالمختلف القوميات في
ايران دعت الى الاحتجاج اليوم همم
صباحا بدات الاضراب في مدن كردستان في
مدينه الشمندج عاصمه كردستان ايران وايضا
في مدينه شقج
مسقط راس ماشا او جينا امينه التي اشعل
قتلها نيران الاحتجاجات في ايران
ايضا شهدت اضراب واغلاق المحارم التجاريه
وايضا في مدينه بوكان ايضا هذا كان في
البدايه اليوم اغلاق المحل التجاريه همم
في ساعات همم القادمه همم قد يتم اغلاق
همم المحاله التجاريه في المدن الاخرى من
كردستان
وانتقالا الى طهران وشهد الطهران ليله امس
14 نقطه في العاصمه الايرانيه من احياء
العاصمه همم مظاهرات واحتجاجات اما كانت
في الشوارع او كانت من الشرفاء اه خلف
النوافذ ومن خلال هذه الاحتجاجات اطلقوا
شعارات ضد اعلى السلطات في ايران ودعوا
الى الاضراب والاحتجاج اليوم المتوقع ان
تبدا الاضطرابات كما شرط اذا هذه
الاحتجاجات اليوم ايضا يتزامن مع تعيين
قائد جديد للشرطه وهو العميد ردان المعروف
بخبرته الكبيره في قمه الاحتجاجات هل
تتوقع بناء على هذه المعطيات تعاطيا
مختلفا مع احتياجات اليوم
هو اكبر دليل على فشل النظام في اخماده
الاحتجاجات الرادادا له اسود في قمه
الاحتجاجات همم في الحركه الخضراء التي
انطلقت في سنه 2009 احتجاجا على تزوير
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وكان له دور في
عمليات التعذيب التي حصلت في احد السجون
همم
المعروف والسجن تهريجك الذي قتل عدد من
المعتقلين تحت التعذيب لدى يحاول النظام
بهذا التغيير من اشتري الى رادان ارشاد في
رساله الى الشارع باننا اتينا بالرجل همم
الذي لا يرحل ولكن يبدو بان المحتجين
الايرانيين لم يتراجعوا وسوف لن يتراجعوا
ويستمرون في احتجاجاتهم لان ظروف التي ادت
الى الاحتجاب الظروف الموضوعيه التي دفعت
الناس للنجوم الى الشارع لم تتغير هي
نفسها بل اصبحت اشد الوضع الاقتصادي اصبح
اشد من السابق والدولار في حاله صعود
وايضا
التضخم في ايران كل هذه الامور تجتمع مع
بعض الى جانب القلعه
المتظاهرين لكن ماذا عين خبئ السياسيه
الايرانيه هل تنظر بجديه لهذه التظاهرات
كخطر وجودي على هذا النظام ام تنظر اليك
حدث مؤقت سيزول بزوايا مسببات ربما او مع
الوقت
باعتقاد من خلال قراءه سريعه
والنظره موضوعيه الى تصريحات المسؤولين
الايرانيين بما فيهم المرشد الاعلى للنظام
يمكن نستشف منها بان النظام اخذ على محمل
الجد ال ال الاحتجاجات وشعر بانه قد يكون
في بدايه مرحله ان يكون او لا يكون لذا
جاء الى اسلوبه القديم الذي لم يغيره وهو
استخدام القبضه الحديديه ضمن الحل الامني
كحل وحيد للخروج من هذا الماء زق شكرا لك
من دبي كنت معنا الصحفي المتخصص في شان
الايراني
مشاهدينا من الانتفاضه الايرانيه الجديده
التي وصفت بيوم الانتقام لاعدامات بحق
متظاهرين الى تهديدات النظام الايراني
دوليا حيث انتقلت الشرطه الالمانيه رجلا
الايرانيا وشخصا اخر تتهم مسروقات
بالتخطيط لتنفيذ هجمات ارهابيه في البلاد
وذلك باستخدام اسلحه بيولوجيه في منطقه
كاسترول
وافاده مواقع المانيا ان المعتقل كان يخطط
الاستخدام مادتي السيانيد وراسين في
الهجمات في البلده الواقعه وسط المانيا
وكان صعيفه اليوميه ذكرت ان السلطه
الالمانيه تلقت قبل ايام تحذيرا من جهاز
الاستخبارات الاجنبي حياه على وجود تحديدا
بشان هجوم بقنبله كيماويه
منبر ليه مشاهدينا معنا مراسله العربيه
رغده برنامج اهلا بك رغده ماذا نعرف من
تفاصيل حول هذه المحاوله الفاشله
وملابساتها ايضا
الشخصان على ما يبدوهما شقيقان ايرانيان
وبالفعل تم يعني اقتيادهما الى الاعتقال
لان من غير الواضح اذا كانت الشرطه عثرت
على المواد الكيميائيه التي كانت تبحث
عنها
واعتقال او اتقاء هذا الشخصين قيد
الاعتقال وتوجيه التهم اليهما يعتمد على
الادله التي تعثر عليها الشرطه في هذه
الشقه التي تمت مداهمتها منتصف الليل همم
ما يتم البحث عنه ايضا لانه هي مواد
كيميائيه
اشخاص معهد روبوت كوخ همم هو هذا الذي
للامراض المعديه في المانيا والذي يعلم ما
يبدو انه ارسل اشخاص للمساعده في عمليه
التفتيش هذه لانه المواد التي يتم البحث
عنها هي مواد يعني سريعه الانتشار مواد
كيميائيه يمكن ان تنت هو تؤذي به سرعه
كبيره ايضا يعني ال- اا القوات الخاصه
التي نفذت هذه المداهمات كان يرتدون اقنعه
واقيه همم خشيه من العثور على هذه المواد
في الشقه والتعرض والتعرض لها همم غير
الواضح ايضا ما اذا كما هي الاهداف التي
كان يخطط هذا الشخصان همم هذا الايرانيين
لمهاجمتها وما اذا كانت اهداف في البلده
ام خارج البلده ما اذا كانوا يحضرون
الاعتداء يستهدف معارضين ايرانيين ام اوسع
من ذلك لانه تعلم بانه يعني قبل ربما
اسبوعين كان هناك تحذير من المخابرات
الداخليه في المانيا لمنهم من اصول
ايرانيه همم من السفر الى ايران لامكانيه
يعني خوفا من تعرضهم لاعتقال وايضا هنا
التحذيرات يعني دائما متكرره للمعارضين
الموجودين هنا من امكانيه تعرضهم ربما لا
يعمل
همم السف غنيه او عملاقيها الموجودين همم
في المانيا وهم مبسوطون بشكل كبير في
الواقع انه لا معلومات حتى الان حول همم
اذا كان هذان المعتقلان يعملان بشكل فردي
ام ضمن مجموعه معينه
اتباعا عندما تبدا التحقيقات معهم همم
نفهم ما هي بالفعل ما كانت اهدافهم ما هي
دوافعهم من من حصلوا على التوجيه همم ومن
اين يستحصل على هذه المواد الكيميائيه
يعني التي
كما ذكرت في الخبر يعني قبل قليل بين
الشرطه الالمانيه حصلت على هذه المعلومات
من محاضرات يعني وصفات بالصديقه قبلت
الشرطه الالمانيه او يعني المانيا لانه
هناك اشخاص يعطون لعمليه همم الاعتداء
ارهابي بمواد كيميائيه اريد ان اشير الى
انه قبل بدعه سنوات كان هناك يعني حادث
شبيه تم اعتقال شخص من كان يحرج جنسيه
تونسيه مع زوجته الالمانيه من داخل احد
الشقق في المانيا ايضا بعد ان يعني كان
لفت انتباه المخابرات لشرائه مواد يعني
كيميائيه عبر الانترنت كيميائيه عبر
الانترنت يعني وتم اعتقاله وهو الان في
السجن لي فتره طويله حكم عليه كان يعد
ايضا لعمليه ارهابيه حقيقيه حينها بانه لو
نفذ هذه العمليه كان لي همم يؤدي الى
ايذاء وقتل عدد كبير من الاشخاص بسبب يعني
همم ضرار هذه المواد التي كان اخذها خلقه
عليها
في سياق نشاط المقبله شكرا
تحياتي رغده
مشاهدينا كتب المتحدث باسم ضحايا الطائره
الاوكرانيه حامد اسماعيل على تويتر
على يد الحارثي الثوري الايراني
ومازلنا في ايران حيث افادت وسائل اعلام
ايراني بمقتل شخص واصابه اثنين اخرين
بجروح نتيجه عمليه اطلاق نار في شركه
كجسران النفطي بمحافظه
شرطه مدينه
الاف الاسرائيليين يتظاهرون في تل ابيب ضد
حكومه نتنياهو
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد
في مدينه
على نظام القانوني والقضائي المظاهرات
الاسرائيليه نظامها الاحزاب منها حزب
العمل الى احتجاج على اصلاحات قانونيه
لدرجه التاثير السياسي على النظام القضائي
في معتبر مسؤول امريكي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ثاني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه اين القوات
الروسيه
في اوكرانيا
التقدم الكبيره في ذا فويس حاليا 24
ان القوات الاخرانيه استخدام الصاروخ
توشكا او الباستيل خلال قصف مواقع في
المقاطعه
من موسك مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبريه اهلا بك عبدو الجواد اذا
ساعات بعد انقضاء الهدنه حتى بدات الضربات
الروسيه على مواقع الاوكرانيه همم ماذا
نعرف ايضا من معطيات اكثر حوله هذا
الموضوع هذا جواد
مباشره بعد انتهاء الهدنه عند الساعه
الثانيه عشر ليلا بتوقيت المحلي ان كان
للاراضي الاوكرانيه
الروسيه عادت مصر مباشره
لعملياتها العسكريه وصعدت طبعا مباشره
الحديثه بدا مباشره عن اطلاق واعلان
صادرات الانذار واعلان حاله التاهب الجوي
في مدينه يعني في المدن الجنوبيه للاراضي
الاوكرانيه الحديث طبعا دار عن خارف دار
عن بلطفاء دار عن زبروجه طبعا التي شهدت
سقوط عدد من الصواريخ حسب الروايات غير
الرسميه لكنها عسكريه من تلك المصادر طبعا
حاله التاهب الجوي استمرت الى ساعات مبكرا
من صباحا اليوم طبعا بالانتظار بيان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه التي الذي سيتحدث على ما
يبدو عن اعداد يعني الاماكن النقاط البنيه
التحتيه التي تم استهدافها خلال
الامس طبعا احمد من الضروري معرفه ان
الدقيقه السابعه بعد بدايه الكدنه كانت
موعد بدء الضربات الجويه كانت حسب ما تم
نقله من هناك من تقارير ان كانت على
الصفحات العسكريه او على تلغرام الذي
يعتبر نشيطه بين الشعبين الروسي
والاوكراني كان الحديث يدور عند ربه
المكثف احمد طبعا في نقطه اخيره حول
الجانب الاوكراني في بعض المناطق الوصول
عبر سيارات وكان الحديث يدور حول يعني شبه
جزيره القرم ااه مناطق في الميناء هناك
كانت يعني تصلها مسيرات وطائرات من دون
طيار لكن كما يدور الحديث هناك منظمات
الدفاع الجوي وقامت باصطياد هذه النصيرات
طيب بالتوازي مع كل ذلك
وضعها الرئيس بوتين همم هذا معنا كلام
يعني ما زالت قيد الانجاز وهذا يفهم منه
انا قيا هي لا ترى في ما يحدث على الارض
في الميدان تعثرا لخطتها هناك
ده احمد المعذره لم اسمع نهايه السؤال
تعذر خطه موسكو في نعم يفهم ذلك ان
القياده الروسيه لا ترى فيما يحدث في
الميدان تعثر لخططها في اوكرانيا ليس كذلك
هل هذا هو الوضع احمد يعني موسكو تتحدث عن
سيرها بعملها العسكريه وما حدث عشيه راس
السنه كان طبعا ضربه كبيره لكريم لذلك
طبعا تصعيد الاعمال العسكريه التي كانت
موسكو لم تخطط له منذ البدايه اصبح يلاحظ
خلال الايام الاخيره الاعداد يعني خلال
هذه السنه اذا تم مقارنتها بطبعا
الاسبوعين الاخرين من السنه الماضيه نلاحظ
بانها ارتفاع كبير انا نتحدث هنا عن اعداد
الجنود الذين تم تحديدهم او اصابتهم في
المعارك وفي الضربات الروسيه
عن اكثر من 500 شخص في اليوم الواحد
باستثناء طبعا اليوم والنصف لايام الادنى
التي عادت مصر وتحدثت فيها عن قيامها
بتوجيه ضربات كرد فعل لكن الاعداد وصلت
الى 120 طبعا من المتوقع ان تكون الاعداد
متوازيه مع مع حدث يوم امس تحدثنا يوم امس
مع العديد من المحللين في البلاد الذين
يعرفون خبايا المنطقه العسكريه وكيف تجري
العمل هناك البعض منهم يتوقع ان تقوم
موسكو بالدخول الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
اجانب قلبي ضروري في البعض يتوقع تصعيد
كبير من موسكو وسياده لضربتها الجويه خاصه
مع فقد الثقه بين موسكو والغرب بشكل اساسي
واصبح تتحدث على العلن عن هذا الموضوع
باعتبار هذه
العسكري الغربي
الاوكرانيه يعني اخذت تحولات واضحه
الماضيه على الصعيد نوعيه الاسلحه التي
تقدم لاوكرانيه كيف تنظر روسيا تحديدا
لهذا التحول
طب بما يخص هذا الوضع طبعا عن موسكو ترفض
يعني ترفض قولا اساسيا بانه لا يجب ان
يحدث مواجهه مباشره بين موسكو لكنها تنظر
الى مد كيف بالسلاح بانه لا يلعب دورا
محورا كبيرا سوا بايطاليا عمر الازمه
موسكو اصبحت تتحدث بانها ستدخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بشكل اكبر ستوسع هناك بشكل
اكبر وهذا الشيء ملاحظ بان معركه
المناطق التي تشارك فيها طبعا قوات خاصه
احمد وهي تابعه للفاغنر وتابعه للرمضان
وليست تابعه بشكل مباشر الى الجيش الروسي
وهي قوات تعرف بشكل جيد العمليات على
الارض وتعرف معركه الشوارع كيف تجربه
اعتبارها باعتبار ان معظم المقاتلين لهم
بعض طويل في الاعمال القتاليه لذلك طبعا
من سيطر على تلك المنطقه احمد سيحضر
بمنطقه استراتيجيه كبيره وسينشيء حب دفاعي
في يقهره فيما بعد الى التقدم نحو تمام
وكل هذا يدعمه طبعا الطيران الروسي من
الاعلى ان كانت مقاتلات مروحيات او غيرها
والصواريخ التي بدات تتحدث عنها موسكو
الان وقد يتم اطلاقها من البحر الاسود كما
شاهدنا خلال الفيديو
معنا مراسل العربيه
اكد الرئيس السوري
في اوكرانيا لن تكون ممكنه الا بعد انسحاب
الجيش الروسي
مره اخرى على ان طرد الغزال روس من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وعدم السماح لروسيا
بممارسه الضغط على اوكرانيا واوروبا سيؤدي
الى السعاده وقف اطلاق النار واحلال الامن
والسلام
وقال الرئيس الاوكراني ان دعوه في اطلاق
النار كانت خدعه مؤكدا على ان ابتداء
فروسيه اصابت ومناطقه اوكرانيه
عن وقفه اطلاق النار المفترض لكن الحقيقه
هي ان القذائف الروسيه اصابت مره اخرى
مجددا
[موسيقى]
اثار رئيس حزب المستقبل التركي
من يونيو المقبل
اعلنت الحكومه العراقيه ان فتح الطرق
والانفاق في المنطقه الخضراء وسط العاصمه
بغداد اعتبارا من ساعات الصباح الاولى من
اليوم
المتابعه في مكتب رئيس الوزراء العراقي
سيسمح للسياره الصغيره فقط بمرور حتى
الساعه السابعه مساءا يوميا ولا يسمح
بمرور سيارات النقل مع التاكيد بان الطرق
ستكون مفتوحه ذهابا وايابا
[موسيقى]
نشاط او مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
موجود اقاله جديده تضرب تويتر
برعايه الامميه وافريقيه بدء المرحله
النهائيه في العمليه السياسيه السودانيه
اليوم
اهلا بكم
في شركه تويتر اجراء المزيد من تخفيضات
العامه فريق الاشراف على المحتوى العالمي
وفريقه مواجهه خطاب الكراهيه وذكر تقيل
لابلومبيهرج انه تم ايضا الاستغناء عن
موظفين في الفرق التي تتعامل مع سياسه
المعلومات المضله والنداءات العالميه
ووسائل الاعلام الحكوميه على المنصه
تدشن الاطراف السودانيه الواقعه لاتفاق
الايطالي اليوم المرحه النهائيه من عمليه
السياسيه الوصول الى حلول
المدنيه والعسكريه في الخامس من ديسمبر
الماضي
الذي اعدته اللجنه التسيريه لنقابه
المحامين
مشاهدينا معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
محمد عثمان اهلا بكم محمد اذا هل بدات
اجتماعات اليوم وما ابرز المواقف
والتصريحات التي صدرت حول ذلك
نعم اهلا بك احمد ستبدا في الخامسه بتوقيت
الخرطوم السادسه بتوقيت مكه المكرمه هذه
المرحله النهائيه من العمليه السياسيه
التي ابتدات
اتفاق اطاري في الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي
بعدد من الاحزاب المدنيه وكذلك المكون
العسكري حتى الان ما صدر من البعثه الاميه
بعد اليونيكاتس بانها ترحب في بدايه
العمليه همم النهائيه من هذه العمليه
السياسيه والتي ينخرط فيها همم بعض
المكونات السياسيه وكذلك المواقعون على
هذا الاتفاق الاطار في همم اخراج خرائط
عمل وطرائق عمل للوصول الى حلول نهائيه من
اجل الوصول الى حلول نهايه هذه العمليه
السياسيه طيب محمد غدا الاثنين واستكمال
لهذه اللقاء ستعقد غوار الشعب خاصه
بازاله النظام الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
ما المنتظر من هذه الورشه
نعم احمد لفهم طبيعه هذه المرحله النهائيه
من هذه العمليه السياسيه هنالك خمس قضايا
تم تاجيلها من الاتفاق الاطار الذي وقع في
الخامس من ديسمبر وهي قضايا السلام
والعداله والعداله الانتقاليه وكذلك مساله
اصلاح المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه وقضيه
شرق السودان كل هذه القضايا تم ارجاؤها
الى هذه المرحله النهائيه ضربه البدايه هي
يوم الغد وذلك
بمناقشه قضيه تفكيك نظام الثلاثين من
يونيو نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
سيكون هنالك النقاش لعدد من الاوراق من
عدد من السياسيين والقانونيين للخروج
بخارطه طريق حول تفكيك نظامه 30 مليون
وايضا تجاوز كل المطبات والعقبات
والتحديات التي لا تعمل همم اللجنه
التفكيك نظامها 30 يونيون التي حلت في
الخامس والعشرين من همم اكتوبر للعام 20
واحد و20 يعني ستكون هنالك نقاشات عميقه
لمده ثلاثه ايام للخروج برؤيه واضحه حول
تفكيك نظام 30 من يونيو ثم بعد ذلك يبدا
الحديث حول بقيه القضايا همم التي تستكمل
بها الاتفاق هذه القضايا ايضا ملف شرق
السودان الذي سيكون حاضر ايضا في لقاءات
اليوم على رغم ان بعض مكونات شرق البلاد
قد عبرت عن رفضها الاتفاق الاطاري هل
سيكونون حضورا اليوم وهل المؤشرات على
توافق قد يتم في هذا الملف المعقد
نعم احمد الصوتي يتقطع قليلا ولكن ان كنت
تسال تسال عن قضيه شرق السودان هي هي
حاضره بطبيعه الحال وهي من القضايا الخمس
المؤجله من الاتفاق الاطار الذي وقع في
الخامس من ديسمبر ال ال الماضي ولكن هنالك
تحدي ما تل امام هذه القضيه شرق السودان
على اعتبار ان المكونات في شرق السودان هي
منقسمه على نفسها وهنالك تباعد في
المسافات وايضا همم في المواقف ما بين
المكونات التي تمثل شرق السودان وبالتالي
همم هنالك يعني تيارات وايضا المجلس
الاعلى لانظارات البيجامه والعموديات
المستقله يرفض هذا الاتفاق همم الايطالي
وكان قد صرح الناظر محمد امين ترد في
اوقات سابقه بانهم يرفضون هذا الاتفاق
وكذلك الفصيله المنشق ايضا عن محمد الامين
تريك ايضا ينظرون الى هذا الاتفاق الاطار
انه لا يعبر عن قضايا شرق السودان وبالت
يحتاج الى كثير من النقاشات والمراجعه اذا
سنكفي بهذا القدر شكرا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه محمد
عثمان تحياتي محمد
سلطه فوز الجمهوريكي من مكارث برئاسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي الضوء على قدرته على جمع
اعضاء حزبه والحكم بفاعليه مثل ما كان
الحال مع رئيسه المجلس السابقه
احتاج الى 15 دوله اقتراع على مدى اربعه
ايام ومفاوضات صعبه مع اليمين المتشدد في
الحزب الجمهوري لي يفوز برئاسه المجلس في
ليله كانت مليئه بالمواجهه متوتره
والتشويق حتى اللحظات الاخيره
بعد حصول الجمهوريه كبن مكارثي على مطرقه
رئاسه مجلس النواب اثر صفقه ثلاث مفاوضات
شاقه مع اعضاء في حسبه تطرح عده تساؤلات
حول التنازلات التي قدمها
تناز
كبيره كقبوله بشرط اقصى اليمين المتعلق
بطلب اي مشرع اقالته لكنه لم يرى بدا منها
ليفوز بجوله الاقتراع الخامسه عشر ما عكس
اختلالا كبيرا وصفا بانه اعمق خلل نظيفي
في الكونغرس منذ 160 عاما
والجيش
على تقديم اقتراح لعزل الرئيس يجعل مكافي
بالتاكيد اكثر ضعفا الى حد ما لكن هذا
الاقتراح لا يزال بحاجه الى اصوات اخرى
والى تمريره باغلبيه الحاضرنا في التصوير
شروط تقييد ايضا لسلطه في اقرار مشاريع
مهمه مثل تمويل الحكومه وصف الدين وشملت
زياده نفوذ النواب في صياغه التشريعات
واقرارها وزياده مقاعد لجنه قواعد مجلس
النواب واعطاء تفويض اثنتين و70 ساعه
لمناقشه مشاريع القوانين قبل التصويت
عليها الى جانب محاوله تقييد عدد فترات
خدمه الاعضاء في مجلس النواب والشيوخ
ضيقه عليه ان يجمع الجميع معا تماما كما
فعلت السيده في روسيا خلال العام الماضيين
اعتقد انه مع التنازلات التي تم تقديمها
والتي تسمح باجراء تعديلات من الحضور لدى
اعضاء المجلس القدره على التاث
بكار في شدد في خطابه بعد الفوز على ان
المجلس في ظل رئاسته سيتصدى لتحديات
امريكا طويله المدى والديون لصعود الحزب
الشيوعي الصينيه وتعاهد بوقف ما وصفه
بالانفاق المسرف في واشنطن
فيما يقلل نواب جمهوريون من اهميته
تنازلات مكارثي مدركينا بانه لولاها لم
استطاع استماره 14 نائبا ليصوت له يتخوف
واخرون من انها تترك الولاده خلال العامين
المقبلين
رهينه بيد اليمين المتطرف حسين الطاوض
العربيه
من الزمن في منصب رئيس مجلس النواب تسلم
وراءها العديد من الانجازات على مختلفه
المراه الاقوى في سياسه الامريكيه لم تكن
تدري نانسي فلوسي لقبها المستقبلي بعد
عقدين من استلامها لمطرقه رئاسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي
[موسيقى]
الشخصيه الثالثه في ترتيب المناصب في
الولايات المتحده
عصرت اربعه رؤساء بعد ان دخلت التاريخ
[موسيقى]
هندسه بلوزه تشريعه عده منها قانون رعايه
الصحيه وخطوط الانقاذ الامريكيه كما جمعت
اكثر من مليار ومئتين مليون دولار للحزب
الديمقراطي اتصفت بعلاقه متوتره مع الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لتمزق خطاب حاله
الاتحاد في الكونغرس
بعد هجومي انصار ترامب على مبنى كابيت
الهيل اطلقت تحقيقا خاصا وتزعمت حمله
الديمقراطيين لعزل ترامب
الثانيه اليوم اطلقتها الى كيف المكرسي
الجمهوري
قررت السلطه الفلسطينيه المضيئه في جهوده
لمواجهه الاجراءات العقابيه التي اقرتها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في حقها حيث دعى
الرئيس عباس للوحده الداخليه وانهاء
الانقسام لتوحيد الجهود
اولى حلقات المواجهه بين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده والسلطه الفلسطينيه
بدات وزير الامن القومي بنجبير بدا عمله
باقتحام الساحات المسجد الاقصى فرد
الفلسطينيون بالتوجه الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه ما اثار غضب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لتقر سلسله عقوبات تنوعت بين الشخصيه
والماليه
هذه الاجراءات لن تسنينا عن مواصله حراكن
السياسي والدبلوماسي وعلى المسار القانوني
الدولي ليس فقط لمحاصره حكومه نتنياهو
اليمنيه الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ دوله
الاحتلال وانما ايضا لمسالتها ومحاسبتها و
لوضع حد لافلاتها المستمر من العقاب نحن
نطالب المجتمع الدولي والاداره الامريكيه
بسرعه التدخل للجسم هذه الحكومه المتطرفه
ووضح حد لتنفيذ برنامجا الاستعماري
وفقا مصادر اسرائيليه فان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اختارت عقوبات محدده بحيث لا
تؤثر بشكل مباشر على الانتعاش الاقتصادي
للمواطن الفلسطيني ولا تضر بالمنظومه
الامنيه لسلطه الفلسطينيه
العقوبات استهدفت عرقله حركه بعض
المسؤولين السياسيين واستمرار مصادره جزء
من اموال الحكومه الى جانب مواصله التطبيق
على المؤسسات القانونيه والحقوقيه العامله
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه والغاء بعض
الموافقات على البناء في المناطق
الفلسطينيه الخاضعه لسيطره اسرائيل اخطر
ما في هذه الاجراءات انها تاتي ضمن برنامج
حكومه وسياسه معلنه وخطوط عريضه تدعو الى
تقويض السلطه بشكل
الضفه ويحسن الصراع ربما هذا يجعلها يعني
حلقه في سلسله اكثر خطوره وابعد مدى على
المدى المنظور خاصه في بيتعلق بالسرعه
وحسمه يدرك الفلسطينيون ان الاخضر في توجه
الحكومه الاس الحاليه لم ياتي بعد والذي
قد يكون على شكل عمليات عسكريه واسعه ضد
مدن فلسطينيه بعينها هو شرعنه بؤر
استيطانيه ومصادره اراضي واسعه تنهي اي
امل باقامه دوله فلسطينيه متصله سبق لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو في
قمه مواجهاته مع حركه حماس في غزه ان سمح
بتدفق الاموال الى القطاع وحافظ على تنسيق
الامن مع السلطه الفلسطينيه اذا فالوضع
الاقتصادي العام للفلسطينيين وقوه السلطه
من الناحيه الامنيه هي مصلحه لاسرائيل فهل
سيحافظ نتنياهو على هذه السياسه امس يدفعه
وزراه المتطرفون لتغيير هذه السياسه
وتغيير قواعد اللعبه برمتها عبد الحفيظ
جعمان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
سلسله التعديات الحوثيه في اليمن استولى
الحوثيون بالقوه الجبريه على ارضنا يملكها
مواطنون في محيط العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء
الحمله الفرنسيه في الاستيلاء على الاراضي
نفذها عشرات العسكريين المسلحين منذ
اسبوعين حتى غطت مساحه تتجاوزه
متر مربعين في الاراضي والمزارع في مديريه
بني مطر
محاوله اختراق حوثيه في الجبهه الجنوبيه
من محافظه المغرب الشرقي
في ظل لي اشهر الشتاء البارده والازمات
التي تعصف باليمن يكافح النازحون في
محافظه مارب من اجل البقاء على قيد الحياه
تضيق الارض على اهلها وما ضاقت البلاد
يوما ميليشيات الحوثي على مدار السنوات
الثماني الماضيه تحاصر محافظه مارب
اليمنيه واعمالها مزقت بنيه ساكنيها اطفال
في ربيع العمر اثقلت كاهلهم هموم الحياه
التي صعب على ذويهم من قبلهم حملها
نقص في الغذاء او بيئه وامراض ومصاعب
اقتصاديه جميعها ازمات يكافحها اكثر من
مليونيه مني من اجل البقاء على قيد الحياه
خلال اشهر الشتاء الطويله وسائل التدفئه
شبه معدومه في النهار شمس خجول وفي الليل
ويل وبرد قارس تقرير صادر عن مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه كشف ان
اكثر من 21 مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه حاليا في وقت تواجه المساعدات
صعوبه في الوصول الى المخيمات
بظل الحصار المفروض من قبل ميليشيات
الحوثي
غرباء في ارضهم باتوا واصبحت حجاره الوطن
مكانا لاستراحه قصيره ربما قبل السير على
طريق المجهول
الى شمالي غربي ليبيا حيث يقصد السياح حول
العالم مدينه غريان لزياره الكهوف بنيت
منذ 2300 سنه اختارها النبيون القدماء لان
درجه حرارتها معتله طوال العام الكهوف
حفرت بطريقه بدائيه داخل سفح الجبل
ويطلقون عليها اسم بيوت الحفر او الداموس
واصبحت هذه التحف المعماريه التي يقطنها
بل التي يقتلون بين جدرانها مزار تاريخيا
[موسيقى]
قاسيه في مظهرها الوعر رئيفه في تل ابيبها
الدافئه تجاويف سفوحها بات التحفا معماريه
في التاريخ المعاصر تعود الى عصرين من
الزمن لكن ما صمد منها لا يقل عمرها عن
ثلاثه قرون كانت بيوتا تضم الليبيين بين
جدرانها الصخريه تلك المدينه يحكي قصتها
اذ قيل ان الجزء الاول من الكلمه يعني
الكهف اما كان نسبه الى امبراطور رومانيا
كان يقتلها تشق الحياه سبيلها في لب
الجبال وتمضي الايام دون ان يبلى اساسها
لتصبح مازارا تاريخيا يستقطب السياح حول
العالم الى قمه الجبل الغربي على علو 700
متر
عائلتي بالحج التي ابت ان تهجر هذا المكان
على الاقل ان تدعى له نصيبا من الذكريات
كواجبا يقع على عاتق افرادها كورثه لهذه
الكهوف
الوضع الامني انه لكن في تحسن طبعا الوضع
الامني جيد في مدينه الخريان طبعا
التوافذ الزوار من جميع انحاء العالم من
اليابان منها اوروبا من بريطانيا من
امريكا من من التايلاند ما نزلوا اطلق
عليها الليبيون بيوت الحفر او كما يسمونها
الدموس مساكن بنيت بشق الانفس وبادوات
بدائيه
وبقدر رحابتي صدر حفرها وسعه هي تلك الغرف
تهب فيها نسمه الماضي بعبق
[موسيقى]
التاريخوا بظلالها وهوائها الذي يبقى صيف
شتاء عند درجه حراره لا تتخطى العشرين
اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]
في هذه
الوقفه التحليليه لما يجري من تداولات
باسواق المنطقه بما فيها السوق السعوديه
في اولى جلسات هذا الاسبوع الصوره متباينه
المؤشر لازال يتماسك فوق مستوى 10500 نقطه
قيمه تداول الضعيفه لطاقه تداول ايضا عربي
ومحدود في انتظار بالطبع المحافظات
الرئيسيه للسوق وهي بالطبع نتائج الشركات
لربع الاخير من 20 22 مسقط تقريبا بيتراجع
بنص نقطه مئويه مؤشر الاول يرتفع بشكل جيد
جديد 0.6 هذا الاسبوع سوف
تنضم من مؤشر الرئيسي الى المؤشر الاول
المؤشر الاول شهد ارتفاعات جيده على مدار
السنه الماضيه بحدود السته ونصف المئه
الاسهم الاكثر ارتفاعا بين تيتانيك ايضا
منذ صباح هذا اليوم حمادي نراقب حلواني
اللي اعادت هيكله ق همم او مرابحه قائمه
مع مصرف الراجحي والغرض الرئيسي هو تخفيض
تكلفه هذا التمويل السهم منذ الصباح مستقر
على ارتفاعات بحدود تسعه شعر النقطه
المئويه نظره على باقي الاسهم وايضا السوق
الكويتيه لازال بطبع الاهتمام
بالشركات القياديه اسواق عبد الله العثيم
يتحدثون عن رئيس تنفيذي جديد تمتعينه من
قبل مجلس اداره الشركه هذا بالنسبه للسوق
السعوديه سوق الكويتيه كما ذكرنا شركات
القياديه تقود هذه الارباح في ظل ترقيته
وترقب ترقيه 54 شركات من السوق الرئيسيه
الى المؤشر الاول النفس السلوك من قبل
مستثمرين
الاهتمام بالشركات القياديه بشكل رئيسي
زين على ارتفاع البورصه ايضا الافكو
مشاريع اذا هذا ما لدينا الان ليس هناك
الكثير من اخبار الشركات التي يمكن ان
تحرك السوق ولكن تبقى الصوره بشكل عام
تراجعات اسعار النفط على مدار الاسبوع
الماضي باكثر من ثمانيه في المئه تعكس لن
اتخوف من الضغط على الطلب خلال هذا العام
20 23 وايضا ارقام البطاله التي صدرت لشهد
ديسمبر من الولايات المتحده 223,000 وظيفه
احسن من التوقعات تراجع في مستوى البطاله
لثلاثه ونصف ولكن وثيره التوظيف بدات
تتباطا اذا عوده الان الى زميل احمد من
ستجهات العربيه بالرياض
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد تظاهر المئات
من جماعه الستات الصفر في باريس احتجاجا
على اوضاع المعاشيه واصلاحات الحكوميه
مرتقبه حول قانون التقاعد معلين بذلك
انطلاق الحركه احتجاجيه في فرنسا للعام
الجديد
للعام الجديد
نريد مجتمعا جديدا لدينا المجال لبناءه
لكن الحكومه هنا من اجل هدمه لن ننخدع
وسنكون حاسمين حتى لو لم تكن اعدادنا
كبيره في وجه هذه الاتهامات تدافع الحكومه
بالقول ان السياق الذي تشهده تظاهرات الان
مختلف عن ما كان عليه الحال عند ولاده
حركه السترات الصفر عام 2018 المتحدث باسم
الحكومه يقول ان نسبه البطاله انخفضت
والحد الادنى للاجور ارتفع لكن بالنسبه
للبعض هي ادعاءات بعيده عن الواقع
نوفو فلوغيا لم نعد نملك شيئا واكثر من
ذلك في بلد الديمقراطيه والحريه وحقوق
الانسان يجب ان تقوم بتصوير الشرطه كيف
تحيط بالمتظاهرين
مع المتظاهرين حيث لم يسمح لاحد منهم
بالخروج عن مسارد تظاهره وسارت قوات
الشرطه معهم كتفا لكتف منعا لحدوث اعمال
شغب طغت على المشهد الاحتجاج طيله السنوات
السابقه فادي دهوك العربيه باريس
كما توقع الفرنسيون المفاجات كبيره على
صعيد الطاقه فمع بدايه العام الجديد بدات
تتكشف التكاليف الكبيره لفواتير الكهرباء
التي يترتب على المواطن دفعها بعد ما
ارتفعت اسعار الطاقه في اوروبا وقد تهدد
هذه الازمه استمرار بعض المصالح كالمخابز
التي تعتمد بشكل كبير على استهلاك
الكهربائي في اعمالها
قائمه التراث العالمي اصبحت المخابز
الفرنسيه هذا العام تعاني بشكل كبير بسبب
ازمه الطاقه ما يجعل هذا القطار في مازق
حقيقيا يهدد وجوده في حال لم تستطع الدوله
ايجاد حل مقنعا لدعمه
لم يحمل العام الجديد الخير لاصحاب
المخابز في فرنسا بسبب ازمه الطاقه
المستمره فمع بدايه الشهر الاول من السنه
تبين انه يتوجب عليهم دفع فاتوره كهرباء
باهظه الثمن كصاحب هذا المخبز الذي تجاوزت
فاتورته الاخيره
12000 يورو بعدما كان يدفع 2800 يورو
شهريا في السابق قبل الازمع هذه الصدمه
جعلته يخرج عن صمته ويطالب الحكومه
بالتحرك
الطاقه كثيرا كما ان فواتير الكهرباء
ارتفعت فجاه والحكومه اعلنت عن اجراءات
لدعمنا لكنها غير كافيه فما زال الجزء
الاكبر علينا دفعه وكل ما كانت الفاتوره
كبيره كلما صعبت تسديدها السكان هنا ايضا
غاضبون ويشعرون بالخوف من ان تؤدي هذه
الازمه الى اخلاق المخبز الوحيد في قريتها
اننا نوافقه تماما لانه من غير المقبول
الا تقوم الدوله بفعل شيء لقد اصبحنا
نهائي فليس المخبز فقط من يدفع الثمن بل
نحن ايضا من جانبها اعلنت الحكومه عن
مساعد هذا القطاع من خلال تاجيل الضرائب
واشتراكات الضمان الاجتماعي للخبازين فيما
وجه الرئيس الفرنسي كلمه
الطاقه حذفهم فيها على مساعده المخابز
والشركات الصغيره زينه عادي العربيه باريس
افادت هيئه الارصاد الجويه الاستراليه بان
الفيضانات التي حطمت الرقم القياسيه في
شمال غرب البلاد ادت الى عزل بلدات كثيره
مع استمرار الاحوال الجويه السيئه التي
بدات قبل ايام وتحديدا في منطقه الكمبرلي
في ولايه استراليا الغربيه كما تسببت
الفيضانات الغزيره التي اجتاحت غرب البلاد
في تدمير طرقات وانهيار جسر ايضا
[موسيقى]
منحت اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه
موافقه على عقار اللي كان ماب الخاص
ايجابيا حتى الان
[موسيقى]
ولا مشاهدينا بقي ان نذكره بابره العناوين
وصلت تمديد الدولي لقمه الاحتجاجات متباشر
ايران يتاهبون للرد على النظام بيوم
الانتقاء
بمعلومات الاستخباريه اجنبيه المانيا
تعتقل ايرانيا بتهمه الايرانيين بتهمه
التخطيط لجنه هجوم باسلحه
كبير
برعايه الامميه وافريقيه بدء المرحله
النهائيه في العمليه السياسيه السودانيه
اليوم
نهايته هذه السارق اخباريه مشاهدينا شكرا
لحسن متابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]